sur route dont florence foresti on va
revenir sur le cacher voilà pour cette
soirée de vendredi parce qu'il ya plein
de gens qui ont dit elle a touché son
cachet donc elle devait rester jusqu'à
la fin sachez que voilà alors je vous le
dis on va vous dévoiler les cachets de
l'or les cachets des chaque présentateur
des présentateurs depuis 2012 je vous le
dis c'est entre 30000 euros
voilà je vais pas dévoiler tout le monde
meilleur c'est entre 30000 euros
voilà florence foresti l'avait touché
50000 euros en 2016 bien voilà voilà
après manu payet 45000 euros et florence
foresti cette année sachez qu'elle a
touchée je vous le dis c'est une info
elle a touché 130000 euros soit 30
millions trente mille euros pour ses
auteurs un don qu'elle a touché pour
elle voilà son âpre entre 100 et 120
mille euros boel voilà sont absents et
ça on va me lis la princesse non mar fc
franches franchement meilleur que c'est
dégueulasse et est démago parce que
malgré tout mais si on me donnait dans
les salaires ou alors au quotidien elle
va roulent en mercedes grâce à la paix
doit pas parce que je dise que encore
une fois elle n'a pas volé cet argent qu
au delà de la demande et j'imagine que
c'est cacher on lui a proposé il a
proposé personne ne voulait y aller
cette année oui il ya ceux qui demain on
nous confirmer qu'il avait confirmé
cette somme en jeu alors moi je n'avais
pas oui j'avais le chiffre de cent mille
effectivement à ça mais voilà j'avais ce
chiffre là donc ça ça correspond mais
encore une fois c'est complètement idiot
de dire ouais l'est pas resté jusqu'au
bout et c est la poser sur la table il
ya deux semaines demandé un canal 1 elle
leur a posé sur la table que si polanski
était dans la salle
quitte à faire une rupture de contrat
elle ne présenteraient pas la soirée des
les tournées par mona n'en était pas
n'était pas mais tu es vraiment qu'ils
étaient guettés par et met alors à bas
l'armée du alors du fait 3,6 g 12
clients à migrer sortie des douches
jean-yves le 12 je ne vous avais 20
minutes
ok suppose de savoir savoir une chose
avec florence foresti attend lé est la
défend des mouvements très bien de
décembre sera bien ram décemment elle
pouvait pas rester vous aidant le bien
regarder ma maman enfin travail on le
fait jouer bouchaoui jour en librairie
je suis désolé raymond femme anne
krystel sont pas comme ça qui va prendre
un coup quand a signé un contrat avec je
sais pas à l'académie des césar au canal
+ c'est qui qui lui a donné des 100000
ses calculs à l'insulté canal+ toi tu
prends de 120 mio christophe dix ans
mais il en d'une vive l'anarchie démago
je m'en fous venait me dire que c'est
démago disait démago présente une vie à
la touche et en une soirée ouaip
apparaissaient les dix dernières minutes
dix ans d'une vie art espace dix
dernières minutes à 120
alors venez il est le porte parole jean
lesquels elle joue il avait alors par
alourdie par les réservoirs en camions
des bus